Matthew it's so wonderful to be here
with you today thank you for having me
it's super dope of course it is dope so
let's start right now by you telling me
what exactly your company does so we
build software for insurance for big
buyers of insurance to manage your
insurance workflows so picture you're a
company like uber Airbnb lift you need
to run essenti background checks on all
your drivers and all your hosts every
time there's a rental or a trip you need
to have some sort of insurance policy on
one of those and if there's ever an
accident or a claim filed you need
somebody to manage it for you and so we
build the software for companies like
that to essentially manage all of their
insurance workflows very cool and how
did you come up with this idea so it
goes back a number of years my brother
and I a couple years ago started a
company out of our dorm room that would
essentially let college students rent
cars out from one another and so that
story is actually pretty funny we went
to a small school called Babson and
wellsy
Massachusetts and this was back in like
2018 Uber Eats wasn't around door Dash
gopuff all of these guys weren't back
around back then and we really wanted
Pizza one night and Papa Johns would not
deliver a Babson so my brother and I
tried calling him to bribe him they
wouldn't bring the pizza and so we had
to order from a local shop and when the
pizza arrived my brother walked outside
to grab it and saw the parking lot
packed to capacity and thought Oh man
it'd be super cool if we could rent
another student's car out and go pick up
the pizza right and so when we started
that business it was called Lula rides
insurance was always a tricky situation
because 18year olds renting cars from
other 18y olds was not this it was not
the most enticing thing for insurance
companies and so we had to go back to
them and tell them all right what if we
run everybody under some sort of
background check what if we organize the
policies in a specific way on every
rental what if we manage claims in a
specific way and so we had to build out
a bunch of insurance tools for that app
and crazy enough out of our dorm room we
ended up launching it September 1st 2018
it became a top 100 app on the App Store
um members I'm more than 500 campuses in
all 50 states it was really funny
because people thought it was this big
company and it was two kids out of a
dorm room and when Co shut down college
campuses it forced us to shut down that
business and so we had lost everything
Nega well we always say negative $2,800
in your bank account two colleages
dropouts Dead start up in the middle of
a global pandemic we had to move back in
with our parents and everything and as
we were trying to figure out what we
were going to do with our life we got a
call from an investor that had passed on
us but we had M we had maintained a
pretty good relationship and he went he
called us and was like hey um one of my
buddies has this opportunity with a US
military they're trying to launch a car
sharing program on Military basis in
Germany and the United States the
insurance companies want them to screen
Drive administer policies and manage
claims in a specific way can you help
them and so sure enough Mike when I get
on to the call with these people we're
like hey we have this beautiful car
sharing app we'll white label it to you
for cheap and they're like no we just
care about the insurance side of things
and so when they asked us what it was
going to cost I was ready to say like
$115,000 I didn't think it was going to
be a lot of work and Michael was the
more financially literate out of two of
us he was at he tells him
$250,000 and so I hit him in the middle
of the com like you're an idiot you just
cost us the deal and the guy on the
other side is like oh man if there were
anything less I'd be concerned and I
looked at Michael and I said mother
effer how bad do we just shoot ourselves
in the foot and um as soon as that
happened we were like oh man people
would buy us for buy this insurance
software and so that was when we started
this new business towards the end of
2020 and um it was basically helping
these big buyers of insurance manage
their insurance they're running
background checks on customers and
employees organizing their policies and
managing their claims so what made you
think that you know you could jump from
College Dropout to to being a Founder
like what made the the risk worth reward
for you there for me it was one of the
situations
where I was in the middle of global
pandemic so even if I wanted to go back
to school I didn't know what this
situation was going to be with school
the other thing that had happened was we
had raised a few $100,000 investors for
that first business and I couldn't
fathom calling them and saying yo I lost
your money and so my brother and I were
like we can either tell them y we lost
your money or we can tell them hey we're
going to start a new business um we'll
just let your Equity roll into this new
one and so we had always told ourselves
we learned so much from that first
business we could almost guarantee
success on the next one and we felt
wrong that we always felt like it
wouldn't be cool to for those guys to
see us celebrating a success in the
future and being like Oh the twins lost
me money and it's it wasn't even about
the money per se because these were all
very affluent guys the $100,000 they put
in were not going to was not going to
make a difference in their life it was
more just the principle and so we've
always just had this weird unusual
confidence in our abilities and I think
a lot of that just stems from hearing
the stories of our grandparents coming
to United States and everything they
overcome and it was like if they
overcame it why can't we and that's what
honestly gave us so much confidence and
so when we had this next idea for this
new business a lot of it was just we
don't really have options we can't go
back to school because we don't know
what the Market's going to look like
nobody's going to hire us with our
current experience or our current resume
and we don't want to call these people
and tell them hey we lost your money and
so that was really the acting motivation
as to all right this is why we're going
to stretch something new and we're just
going to find a way to make it h make it
happen there's no plan B besides success
how did how did those initial investors
react then when you said hey we're we're
going to switch gears and do this new
company they were they were super salty
like there's no other way to put it
they're like we invested in a car
sharing app now you want to do something
with insurance yeah and we told them
like look college campuses are closed
there's nothing we can do with this old
app but insurance is actually a bigger
deal right now than ever before because
if you think about it insurance is that
one cost you want to cut but you can't
afford to eliminate cuz you need it for
legality purposes and all that and in
the middle of the pandemic where people
were being where people couldn't hire
more employees they weren't necessarily
paying rent the cost of insurance is
more exasperated than ever because it
was they were still being forced to pay
it right and so we basically were able
to come out and say all right we'll go
to all these different companies that
are buying insurance and tell them hey
if you use Lula to run background checks
on customers and employees and all that
that we're actually going to save you
money from an insurance perspective and
so because of the economic Times people
were way more willing to listen to two
kids telling them hey you're going to
cut your insurance cost by x% if you use
our software and so I think that I think
the timing itself of being in the middle
of pandemic actually worked out really
well for us that's and I love those
stories that go from like there's this
awful event and then it actually FS
sucess it was the best thing that
happened to us um and I think like
insurance obviously in up markets is
great but when people are strapped for
cash they still see the they can cut
their they can cut their rent they can
cut their head count but they can't cut
their insurance or they can't cut it
entirely right and so if you can go to
them and tell them hey we're going to
help reduce it they're forced to pay
attention whether or not they want to
totally so talk to me then about your
fundraising Journey since then what's
what's that been like for you so I
always say we are the most rejected
founders of all time for that for that
first business we got rejected by
babson's accelerator program the first
time Mass challenge Tech Stars when we
started gaining a lot of ground in April
2019 and we tried to raise capital for
the first time I remember we had
probably a few hundred bucks left in our
bank account and we decided to buy
one-way tickets to San Francisco and
people buy hear that story and they're
like oh you had so much confidence you
booked a oneway ticket you knew you were
going to close the deal I was like no we
just didn't have money for the return
flight and so we went out to San
Francisco and we emailed 532 investors
wow the first 525 either ignored us
passed rejected us investor
526 ends up answering and he's like hey
can you come next month there's an event
and I was like no if you let me I'm
Leaving On a Plane tomorrow to Boston to
go close my seed round um he's like all
right can you come in three weeks I'm
like no I'm going to go close my seed
round in Boston if you let me get on
this flight he's like all right can you
come tomorrow
and then I was like yeah sure so we go
to the event and my brother gives the
worst picture of his life he was just
like super nervous and um as soon as he
gets off stage there was an investor
waiting for him and uh it was one of the
investors from this firm and she's like
hey Ali Resa the GP wants to meet you
and then the rest of the investors that
on that list of 532 passed but all I had
to say fundraising for us was always a
nightmare or on it wasn't because we had
a bad business it was just when we
started gaining popularity Uber and lift
were getting ready to go public so
everybody was just petrified of them as
competitors and then when we had the
idea for this business again because of
our failures raising Capital because it
was in the middle of global pandemic we
took a different route we actually
before we ever spoke to investors we
went out and we got contract signed and
then once we had about 23 letters of
intent we took that to investors and
were're like hey look people are willing
to pay us for the stripe for insurance
and uh because that's like what we call
it the stripe for insurance and so at
that point we were able to raise
$200,000 from next VI Ventures um and
then we were able to raise a few
$100,000 here and there but nothing
substantial and then we basically in
summer of 2021 jumped straight to the
series a which was 18 million and then
there was a bunch of people I joined
after that and then fast forward to
today we've raised about $60 million
from Founders fund kosla soft Bank
Bill Amman and it's been insanely
different like the last round of funding
that we just like our series
a I remember there was 40 firms that
were fighting for our series a and I
thought that was the craziest thing
given where we had been not too long
before and then we raise our series B
this time around and I kid you not we
had over 130 firms organically reach out
to us in a span of 30 days and so it's
been the most insane thing to go from
the two kids that couldn't have
investors yeah even care for us to now
basically have every everybody that we
dreamt of in our inbox and and they stay
persistent asking us if we want to raise
even though we don't anymore so the
Dynamics have been incred they've
changed so fast and again this has all
been in less than three years so it's
it's been a really it's been interesting
to be in the midst of it all that's
crazy congratulations on that thank you
um so talk to me now about the the scale
of your company how many customers do
you have how are sales doing anything
you can share with us yeah so we started
we started actually on this new version
of the business towards the end of 2020
and then we went out to Market with a
real product in 2021 and that first year
we were able to hit the million doll AR
Mark and then in the past I'd say 16
months it's just gone Gang Busters we've
um we've grown almost 45x in the last 15
months will be the fastest Insurance
startup to hit $100 million
ARR will also hit profitability next
year so not only will be one of the
fastest software companies to hit that
Revenue Mark but we also be one of the
only ones that have done it in a super
Capital efficient way and so yeah the
company's drawing revenu is growing
quite a bit and one of the things that
we haven't even publicly announced which
I'll say here because I'm super pumped
about it okay is um is our new AI
product and so we have an AI product
called Gail generative AI by Lula and it
was the first AI to just pass the State
Licensing exams um so to be able to sell
insurance and so now uh what it is it's
basically a voice-powered AI that can
sell insurance to your customers and can
service them and so if all of a sudden
you call one of our customers you'll
think you're speaking with a human but
in reality you're speaking with a robot
and the robot can speak Spanglish can
speak English Spanish or Spanglish and
uh and we're building in a way where it
can you can you can put together you can
give it slang you can give it certain
dialects certain accents and stuff all
of a sudden uh a Puerto Rican calls the
phone they're not going to think they're
speaking to a robot because it's not
going to have a Puerto Rican accent and
so yeah we're we'll be announcing that
in a couple of weeks but that's probably
what I'm most excited about that's
awesome and how do you think about you
know the ethics of that with AI I know
that's such a Hot Topic right now but
how are you looking at it I think of it
I think of it when it comes to the
ethics I actually think it's it's e
it's I think it's a moral obligation to
use this technology because one of the
things that I think about in insurance
and this is I think about it all the
time as a kid that was taken advantage
of in the early days of the other
business Ula like heavy Insurance
component people saw two young kids they
can uh that had raised $200,000 and they
were going to try to squeeze any every
penny out of us and so we had Insurance
Brokers that misled us gave us false
information tried to to put in these BS
terms and we actually found out a couple
times that those things weren't legal
and you see that across the insurance
industry left and right that a lot of
these Brokers because they're going
after their own ulterior motives higher
commissions all these different
things they tell their customers oh you
need this you need that and they're
really just driving up the cost of the
deal so they get higher commissions
right I think this type of stuff is
actually perfect because the AI is not
going to be there not collecting
commissions on its own behalf
and so it's not going to be misleading
the customers it's not going to be doing
any of that weird stuff I think the
other thing too is if you look at the
insurance Market as a whole premiums are
at an all-time high and a big reason for
that is because labor costs are at an
all-time high and so you look at Florida
for instance people are seeing their
insurance costs go increase 100%
year-over-year and it's driving people
out of business and it's really
impacting them and so now that you have
this technology it doesn't need
commissions that's 20% more that can go
into the customer's pockets and so to me
there's certain there's definitely going
to have to be some sort of regulatory
piece that overlooks it because like
anything people are going to take
advantage of it but I think to a certain
extent we have a moral obligation to use
it because it can help it can help
people in so many different ways like
giving them affordable insurance yeah
that's an interesting way of looking at
it too yeah I mean that's our whole goal
my whole goal is to give make Insurance
available to everybody
as we always say in the universe because
we'll eventually be on Marge now with
Elon but I think AI is the first thing
that actually allows for people all over
the world get it insurance for a super
affordable rate what would you say is
the most challenging part of running
your
company I would say so people are always
going to talk about like oh the hiring
the business the product like we deal
we're in the world of insurance and so
it's super heavily regulated for me it's
not even that like the hardest Thing by
far was this was my first job like the
only my first real job the only job I
had before this was selling women's
shoes at Nordstrom for like two months
and then working on my family's farm and
so the hardest thing for me was there's
no there's a bunch of articles that tell
you how to make your first
$10,000 or your first million dollars
nobody ever tells you what it's like to
go from a million dollar in Revenue to
$50 million in 15 months or anything
like that right and so just having to
navigate all those different things on
your own is super tough and of course we
have investors and advisers but again
they haven't even gone through that and
so dealing with life changing so fast
I'd say that's probably like the
toughest stuff and I think the other
thing too
is um to a certain P to a certain extent
like the mental side of it I'm not
talking about like depression or
anything like that I'm talking more so
just the challenges you now have 130
adults and their families depending on
you when two years ago is just my
brother and I like all those different
things the magnitude of decisions um
like sometimes you're just really tired
and you can't take a day off because you
have all these people waiting for you
and so it's uh yeah and then the other
thing too like you see all these other
people that are in your cohort that
they're killing it and sometimes you
sorry for the curse like sometimes you
look at yourself and you're like am I
am I stupid but those are thoughts
that actually come into your mind and so
from me the best thing that's helped
with that is reading autobiographies cuz
like you'll see Elon Musk out the same
thing you'll see Brian chesky from
Airbnb like they all went through time
periods of time in their life where they
had these same thoughts and so it would
be unusual if you didn't have these
thoughts and so that to me is like the
hardest part just like the mental piece
of it but it's it's incredible when you
see that um It's Not Unusual to think
that it'd be unusual if you didn't have
those thoughts what would it take to get
you to sell your company and is that
your goal ever no um it sounds a little
bit morbid but my brother and I always
say our exit strategy is deaf it's uh
it's either a company dies or I die in
60 70 years like right now I'm I'm
thankfully at a point where I don't have
to worry about money and setting the
company wouldn't really change that for
me and so for me the goal is to take the
company public which is what we're being
set up to do and then I want to be
working on this when I'm in my 50s 60s
7s all that like I find this fun for me
I think that's one of the big
competitive advantages that we have is
like people look at this as a job like
to me the way that I grew up playing
basketball cuz I loved it I do this
because I have so much fun and so to
take it to sell it would be essentially
taking away what I find fun and so I
don't really have interest in that it's
not because money at this point wouldn't
necessarily change my life if you could
go back in time and tell your younger
self something the day before you
launched Lula what would you say what
advice would you have this is a this is
a good question it's counterintuitive
but I would say say yes to more parties
like I remember I remember
when like even throughout the whole
duration of time like even now a year
ago like I missed out on so many moments
with all my friends and my family and
stuff like that and a lot of times uh I
was just like oh no I have to work I
have to get this deadline and I realized
that had I turned something in three or
four hours later it wouldn't have
changed anything if I had taken that
vacation wouldn't have changed
everything
now I would have had to maybe come back
from the party a bit early and worked or
maybe I would have had to take my or I
would have had to take my laptop on the
vacation or whatever but for me if I
could go back in time and say say yes to
to all the parties and all the vacations
because you're going to look back on it
one day and be like damn I miss it and
um and I think I missed out on so many
different things because I thought I had
to work and don't get me wrong you still
have to work crazy hours but looking
back on it I could have always come back
early or something like that and I miss
so many many big moments I wouldn't want
to do it again so that's my that's my
big thing to young people is like say
yes to more parties and more vacations
that sounds fun honestly you keep coming
back to to mentioning your family and
your history and and your brother um one
what's it been like to work with a
family member and two how has like your
family and your history shaped what
you're building at Lula I think I always
say um and I used to be like this too
like you always say like Founders or
entrepreneurs successful people the
worst thing you can ever tell them is
you're lucky MH and to a certain extent
I used to hate when people say that but
looking back on my journey I'm the
luckiest person in the world like I won
the lottery when I had my family and I
didn't grow up with money or anything
like that but I grew up on a small farm
my family gave me everything that I
needed to be happy um they were always
so supportive like that was one of the
things I can credit my parents to like
when I was younger and I wanted to go to
the NBA they never told me no you're not
going to make it to the NBA you're going
to grow up to 5'9 and on athletic they
encouraged it like all right you want to
go to the NBA how are you going to get
there m you're okay so you're going to
go take 500 shots a day you're going to
go work out for X number of hours and it
was the same thing with uh with Lula
they were mad when we dropped out cuz
nobody had ever graduated college in my
family and they wanted us to do the same
thing but my dad was like all right
you're making this decision you're going
to work 9 to5 I'm going to make sure you
work 9 to5 and so they gave us that
structure name encouraged it so I always
say like my I owe everything to my
family because even when we failed with
the first startup they could have told
us go back to get a job go do anything
and uh they just encouraged us and so
everything that that I have today I owe
to them and when it comes to
Michael Michael I always say is I'm an
affirmative believer that Michael will
go down as this generation Steve Jobs or
Bezos and um I wish he could have been
here instead of me and I always tell
people people it's like one of the
reason I get so excited to come to work
is like how would you feel if you got to
work with Steve Jobs your generation
every day like you'd be super stoked and
it's been incredible to work with him I
think one of the big things too is
because we're twins we grew up so close
we have an unfair Advantage when I think
about other competitors like we go to
the gym together we uh we live in the
same apartment we drive to work every
day on the same and
so we're always talking and I think one
of the things that's really cool is I
never have to guess his motives and a
lot of times Founders don't know if
somebody's on the same wavelength as
them if somebody has the same character
if somebody has the same ambition I know
how crazy I am and how intense I am and
I have a clone of me and so yeah
literally so while most companies are
are are fortunate they just have one
Elite founder I think we're we're in a
really good spot because we have two of
basically the same person and he's more
business oriented I'm more technology
oriented that's like the big differences
between us but it's been it's been a
dream working with him and I have to
give him credit all the ideas that we've
had have been his result I got CEO
because of a coin toss yeah wow that's
funny that's amazing yeah it's been
awesome yeah so what's what's next for
you any new exciting things in 2024 I
know you told the AI I think I I hate to
say the AI stuff cuz I feel like I'm
riding a trend but I think the I think
the AI stuff is going to be incredible
and we working on it before was the
buzzword it's just now the timing of
things but I think I'm an affirmative
believer that AI generative AI is going
to have a bigger impact on the world of
insurance and the worldwide web and
internet did and when I think about the
landscape of companies that are out
there to actually bring it to the world
of insurance I think we're the best ones
suited for it we've now been in the
insurance industry for a number of years
we're well capitalized have real
customers and real Revenue which allows
us to have real data we can train the
models on and so I think we're in a
really great position I think the other
thing too is that I'm a big believer
that the best time to build a company is
once the market for that particular
company has crashed and so if you look
at stripe for instance stripe came out
after the 2008 Global recession you look
at Airbnb came as a result of the
banking crisis you look at where the
market our Market is for in sharex $50
billion has been invested in sharex the
last decade nobody in this room can
probably name a single um Insurance
unicorn right now like you look at
lemonade root hippo metr mile Trove have
tremendous respect for all of them they
paved the way for us but their stock
prices have tanked and um and so when I
think about the insure Tech Market I
think right now is the perfect time to
build it and I think this technology
generative Ai and what we're doing with
it is going to allow us to pave the way
and build something special and I think
the product that I will die being
remembered for is this product Gail
that's coming out to the market in 2024
do you you mentioned like lemonade and
all those do you see them still as heavy
competition so I never really saw them
as competition this is one of the
interesting things we were fortunate
enough that we always stayed just
technology for insurance Metro root
lemonade all of those they actually
became insurance carriers so they were
paying claims out whenever there was an
accident we always made sure that we
stayed on the software side of things
and early on I want we wanted to go the
route of those guys and when we started
seeing what a regulatory nightmare it
was we decided just stay on software
because I don't have to ask somebody for
permission to launch a new software
product but I have to ask like a million
people permission if I want to launch a
new insurance product and so that was
like the big differentiator between us
and everybody else and that was actually
one of the big issues we had when we
would go raise Capital everybody would
say all right you're inure Tech so you
must be like lemonade and rude and it's
like no they they pay claims we just
focus on the software and so that was
even even now at the size we are that
was still one of the big complication or
complexities that we had it's like hey
don't look at the market for us we're
building something entirely new
excellent well Matthew it's been such a
pleasure to hear your story so thank you
for sitting with me thank you for having
me